the latest on NASCAR which heads into
another weekend of racing with no end to
the controversy involving the only
full-time black driver at its top-level
NASCAR president Steve Phelps released
this photo of a noose found in Bubba
Wallace's garage at the Talladega
Superspeedway last week Phelps said
quote as you can see from the photo the
noose was real important point there FBI
investigators found the rope had been
there for several months and concluded
that Wallace was not the target of a
hate crime
Jericka Duncan spoke with his father in
his fur in his only TV interview since
that noose was found
drinka good morning good morning you
know his father talked about how proud
he is of his son as for NASCAR officials
said that they checked all of the
garages at their tracks and out of the
nearly 1,700 stalls they said only one
of them just one the one that was
assigned to Bubba Wallace had a pull
down rope that was clearly fashioned as
a noose I just see how it's weighing
down on him and wearing him out he's
having sleepless nights I'm worried
Darrell Wallace senior says he feels the
weight that his 26 year old son is
carrying on Thursday NASCAR's president
said that while they don't know who tied
the rope into a noose the ultimate
conclusion for this investigation is to
ensure that this never happens again
what conversation have you had with your
son since the new sensitive of your
surroundings you know know what's around
you who's around you because there's
some crazy people out there and when you
have that conversation that's because of
the move that NASCAR took in reference
to the Confederate flag and your son's
push to try and make that happen is that
right yeah that's correct you know this
has been a stressful couple weeks
earlier this month Bubba Wallace the
only full-time black driver on Racing's
top circuit challenged NASCAR to remove
confederate flags from its events and
they did are you surprised by the steps
NASCAR has taken no I'm not surprised I
mean it's the right thing
there's people that's less uncomfortable
with the flag and are you am i yeah
hi I mean there's only one flag I stand
for and so yeah I mean I'm uncomfortable
the flag and if interviewer with me and
you're uncomfortable with the flag then
I'm on Darrell Wallace senior says Bubba
discovered his love for racing as a
young boy
we bought a go-kart racing and a few
races in you know it got in the way of
his basketball so he kind of had inside
which one he wanted to do and you chose
the racing then we raced every weekend
sometimes three or four times a week to
salute the fans Bubba Wallace one of
NASCAR's biggest names now races all
over the country and his father says
he's proud to see the calls for change
coming from car number 43 and this was
just recently painted and he says he was
moved by Monday's show of support at
Talladega you were watching that I'm
sure on on television how did you feel
when you saw that moment of solidarity I
texted to my family who's chopping
onions because know they was takes and
everybody was crying you know just what
did it mean what did it represent that
they had his back
a Parral moment we've had to jump
through a lot of hurdles and put up with
a lot of stuff from the time he was 9
years old and up until today but you
know we just got to keep going and keep
racing and do what we do NASCAR
president Steve Phelps says that he will
now add cameras to all of the garages
and all members of the Association the
Racing Association will be required to
take sensitivity and unconscious bias
training Gail Oh
Jericka I'm so touched by Bubba Wallace
his dad you could tell he's a proud
father who's concerned about his son and
but what what I keep hearing from
everybody who knows bub is that he loves
to drive he and NASCAR really want to
move on and put this behind them but I
felt like Bubba Wallace the father there
it was such a touching moment of
solidarity the way they all lined up
behind him yeah when what it represented
I mean it's funny because he said he's a
very direct guy and he said a lot of he
feels his sons directness comes from him
but in Nam when he said it just it
really broke him down so yeah he's a
proud dad and now everybody's ready to
move on and we are cheering for Bubba
Wallace is Saturday where every Pocono I
hear cheering for him Jericka thank you
thank you very much